welcome to there be spoilers show I'm
your host definition and those looking
for some scary stories to tell them the
dark are in for a real treat
as the horror adaptation makes its way
across cinemas throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the movie and
discussing how we may see the series
return to our screens with a whole new
host of characters there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't seen the
movie yet don't want to know what
happens then I highly suggest that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for quick in
this video now let's get into my and
they explain breakdown of scary stories
to tell in the dark the film picks up in
the town of Mill Valley America during
the late 60s in it we follow a small
group of youngsters who come across the
Journal of sarah bellows after going
into our mansion on Halloween
Sarah is notorious in the area as are
the bellows who have a reputation in the
town for murder and children so yeah one
star of you avoid avoid avoid anyway as
the kids didn't have TripAdvisor back
then they mistakenly disturbed Sarah's
old room and because of this the journal
that's within the house begins to fill
with stories about how the children will
die after being tormented by a dark
creature the movie expertly crafts its
setting and even now this is primarily
being labeled as a kids film that
doesn't mean that it isn't disturbing
throughout each creature has its own
unique and disgusting feature that
really makes all of their appearances on
screen memorable and pure Nightmare fuel
this film does an expert job of adapting
the source material by Harvin Schwartz
whilst also introducing its own
creatures such as the jangly man who
will probably stick with you long after
you leave the cinema in addition to this
there's Harold who's in a field of his
own the red spot that turns out to be
more than a bad case of bad acne the
dream that is anything but and the big
toe that will leave anyone with a foot
fetish climbing the walls each one
really captures your imagination
and as the children are slowly picked
off one by one we are left with a
handful of survivors most notably Stella
Stella wants to become a writer and
during the movie she realizes that in
order to free herself and her friends
from the curse that she has to expose
the truth about the bellos to the town
after returning to the house she comes
face-to-face with Sarah and after seeing
firsthand what she went through at the
hands of her family promises to bring
light to it and write about it this
seemingly allows Sarah to rest who takes
the creatures with her that she
unleashed mainly the jangly man who is
getting eerily close to taking Ramon and
the curse is lifted and Stella exposes
the truth about the bellows to the town
though we get the impression that not
everyone believes it Ramon is drafted
into the Vietnam War which is a pretty
heart-wrenching moment especially as
SteriPEN sumela that reveals her
feelings for him and overall it's an
ending that sets up a lot down the line
most notably because the final scene in
the film reveals that Stella didn't
return Sarah's journal to the Haunted
Mansion and instead she along with her
father and friend Ruthie who's probably
going to be scarred for the rest of her
life with arachnophobia believed that
there's a way that they can bring back
their fallen friends this is because
some of them were absorbed by the
creatures and the Stella things that
there is hope that they can come back
during the film Stella received a pen
from Sarah that when dipped in blood
could add to the journal and this could
allow her to craft her own creatures and
stories that could potentially bring
back her lost friends we follow the
three as they drive off on their mission
to discover the truth behind the book
and how the magic in it works we get the
feeling though they were able to quell
Sarah's rage and that will lift the
curse they haven't actually discovered
what allowed her to get revenge from
beyond the grave
and this is one of the movie's biggest
mysteries I think that going forward the
group will trace the root of the power
behind the book as well as where the
stories themselves actually originate
from with this power still being out
somewhere in the world that means that
there could be more dangers and those
who read the original scary stories will
know that each tale has its own long and
dark history for example the big toe
comes from a story in which a boy saw a
big toe sticking out of the ground in
his garden and he yanked on it really
hard and pulled it out of the ground
this caused the body that was attached
to it to track him down and there's a
lot that you could do with this sort of
tail and
of discussing how the body got there and
so on well I don't think that that story
would necessarily be adapted just
because it's already featured in this
film and we have had some hints to what
happened
Schwartz himself is written over 80
stories each with its own unique and
evil creature and there's a vast wealth
of material to pull from in terms of
plot devices going forward I think that
the next movie has the potential to be
even darker than this one with the three
perhaps being chased across America
after unwittingly unearthing more
monsters from the other side either way
there's a lot of things that could
happen going forward and I'm really
excited to see which scary stories we
have down the line and now on to my
review I think scary stories to tell in
the dark is a brilliant film and one
that definitely feels like a really good
example of how children's horror can
work and still be very menacing I was
born in the 80s and grew up in the 90s
where kids cartoons and so on all had a
dark side to them that seemed to really
disappear around the turn of the
millennium only to be replaced by rather
soft and overly friendly shows so it's
great to see something in this genre
that feels I could call back to those
days as I think it's all I missed this
movie is designed to give children
nightmares and I genuinely think that
it's gonna succeed in that goal I don't
have any doubt that in 20 years time
when kids have grown up many of them
will refer to this as the thing that
kept them up at night when they were
little it's a really enjoyable film that
creates some brilliant new horror icons
that will no doubt stick with many and
though the film isn't perfect it still
does way more good than bad I had a
great time with scary stories to tell in
the dark and that's why it gets an 8 out
of 10
obviously I loved hear your thoughts in
the film and if you agree with my
comments or not drop your thoughts below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video and want to watch more scary
things then make sure you check out my
full breakdown of the extra eight
minutes of footage that we got but it's
chapter 2 which would be linked at the
end in it I go over everything that you
need to know about the first look as
well as how it was changed from the
source material so it's definitely worth
watching if you want to know more if you
want to come talk to me about movies TV
shows games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best place again touch
with me and it's the perfect way to
suggest new videos and content also just
when I let you know that we're currently
giving away a free copy of Avengers
game on blu-ray - one lucky winner and
all you have to do is like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on scary
stories to tell the dark in the comments
section below the win will be chosen at
random on August the 10th so you've got
one day left to enter and the blu-ray
will be shipped out from them to ever
get surprise so best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you